as the country lost its fever for the
labrador retriever
yes America has agreed on a new favorite
breed they gave dogs like mine a chance
despite being linked to France
yeah according to the American Kennel
Club or
the country's new favorite canine is the
French Bulldog
oh
oh you're gonna hate this segment
so you know what that means
[Music]
I kid
or do I Vizsla is like Percy were never
near the top so he wasn't really any
competition to begin with
basically the Marianne Williamson of dog
breeds
I didn't write that but Labs have held
the top spot for 31 years so it was time
for a new kid on the Block
and it's been a quick rise for the
Frenchie apparently it wasn't even a top
75 breed a few decades ago although that
seems insane I mean
take a look at this fella
[Music]
you know
maybe I'm wrong but I think the producer
who made that montage is gay
[Laughter]
I feel violated
all right Dana I I turned to you uh I I
turned into you
it's it's true
I'm thrilled for you yeah yeah I don't
believe you I am I think you're a much
nicer person now do you think that's
true no I'm not really I think I think
it added another layer of stress oh yeah
well it is another layer of stress it's
also you do get some Joy if you're
taking a lot more pictures now so you're
getting you know you're like getting out
there and the thing is uh the vishla was
never in the running as you said I mean
they get robbed of everything and that's
fine
um and I congratulate the French Bulldog
on this win for a year I think it will
only last a year because the French
always surrender
yeah
this is the first time Dana that I have
done something that like maps with the
mainstream I know it's weird I never
this is like all of a sudden you're
gonna start listening to you know like
Keith Urban and Kenny Chesney ugh
probably already does he just Taylor
Swift no no that it's never gonna happen
uh do you think do you agree with this
uh Joey you're a dog dude yeah you know
I'll be honest my house has a French
Bulldog I won't go so far as to say I
have one
um only only the Gen zeers of America in
2023 would replace a dog that can sniff
out bombs sniff out drugs recover a duck
if the duck ain't dead it'll kill it for
you and bring it back and not even mess
it up uh it can help the blind see it
can help the deaf here it can lay on
your belly and let you know you're about
to have a stroke that's what a lab can
do and only the gen's ears of America
would prefer a dog that looks like it
was born with a stroke can't
think about food without passing gas yes
it's true snores like your bed got
dropped in an old folks home it's so
true and it's so stupid you just have to
convince yourself the stupidity in
itself it's cute
you sound like cheese
I love Chief he's a great dog he kind of
lays right here all four paws up but uh
yeah the dog doesn't have brains God
given oh I love you were accurate but I
still love the dog Paul you actually
believed I wasn't gonna keep him didn't
you I figured by now cat would have that
dog
I think cat kind of hoped right I'm
gonna keep the dog but continue to call
him Gus got fell to remind you of your
failure
well I mean look this breed according to
that article if you read it they are
loud
chubby small
bed and we'll eat anything yes yeah
where am I going with this
and we know next year you'll be walking
around saying oh you know French
Bulldogs like this so last year I was
there already yeah yeah you know so cat
raised yourself it's incoming yeah what
do you make about the criticisms over
these over the French Bulldog you also
have a French Bulldog Carl Carl yes I
think we can like put up pictures or
whatever but I actually mainly want to
tell you something but I think it'll
make you mad at me should I do it yeah
yeah
you have not become Dana you are far
worse
I want to be clear about something when
you guys see him on TV that is the only
time he is talking about anything else
other than the dog really
can you think of another conversation
recently well because he was constipated
and then
yeah constantly he had diarrhea all over
he had diarrhea all over my apartment
and then he got stopped up hear that now
you know how I feel and he
and then he like he pooped all over my
living room but they were solid pools
that's not a condition that's just how
they are
that cycle doesn't stop
you were the one that made me get him I
didn't make you yes you did I helped you
yeah no no that dog is your dog's nephew
yeah it's your my dog that's your dog is
my dog's uncle
with a cervix with a cervix
is a cisgender male
although he doesn't have balls anymore I
just swore
I got it gonna remind you today do I
have to do everything I know it's like
seven it's just I gotta do it I had a
calendar invite for you oh my God good
for you I wouldn't do it at seven months
seven I would wait a weight really yeah
oh okay so what castrate the dog I think
I think you need to give him at least a
year if if not two if you can so that
they can get all the hormones that they
need that's the new science oh and that
dog's gonna need everything it can have
guys all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else